[Music]
hi guys I just want to address this up
top I look like a douchebag thank you
it's not a joke I just want to make sure
you know that I know like I get it I've
seen mirrors I understand that before I
even started talking most of you already
didn't like me and that's okay because
80s movies have taught you to not trust
someone with my hair and bone structure
I get that I'm excited I recently joined
a support group for people who peaked in
high school
it's called Cross Fit the support means
everything that's not a joke actually do
it the crazy part about it is like I
don't think the workouts are good for
you like they sound like they were
written by an undercover chiropractor
trying to drum up business
all right here's twice your body weight
you're gonna pick it up set it down then
scream like a wounded Spartan okay what
about form no time for form just try to
live with your back okay that that
sounds kind of painful don't be a [ __ ]
hey this is partly leaving your kneecaps
you got this awesome
I think I think scientists deserve more
credit I think they have a really cool
job here's why I learned this recently
the G spot the G in G spot if you don't
know stands for graefenburg graefenburg
the anatomist who discovered it and then
named it after himself
what I thought like what it's jammed
like you can understand the difference
between found the g-spot and founded the
g-spot that's a person that's a real guy
I tried to look him up but hard to find
[Applause]
my mom wrote that line don't clap for
that if not that's not true actually I
didn't look him up because don't Google
your hero's know what I mean like I
don't want to know I don't want to know
his first name or where he's from and I
really don't want to know what he looks
like because in my mind I already had
this picture of this guy who's just
barely a dr. Ewing like sleeveless lab
coats beepers and twosies and he's just
standing there looking real smug with
stirrups and a laser pointer just like
yeah that was a that was all me
yeah wasn't even looking for it just
kind of stumbled across it while I was
studying abroad
[Applause]
shots geez Chancellor graefenburg nah
bro she stands for job well done
it uh it goes deeper
it's forwarding actually uh I did some
research for this joke and I learned
that any part of the female anatomy that
is named after a person is named after a
man so all of it Barthel ins Glan skenes
gland graafian follicle x' doctor Kegel
was a man as was dr. fallopian of tube
fame which means that it's all named
after affluent male doctors so the
women's reproductive system is like the
rec center at an Ivy League school right
just like a bunch of dudes like let's go
in there and let's claim what's ours
right that's not gynecology that's just
vaginal imperialism manifest ovaries
voice the the reason I know this stuff
my mother was a biologist and my brother
and I we were raised to never use slang
terms for body parts to always use
proper anatomical terminology and there
are times when this is not very
appropriate like I was with a girl I was
dating one time when I was about two
euphemism her metaphor and in the heat
of the moment I used the word vulva and
she had a similar reaction just like ah
can't you just say vagina I was like
well no because I'm referring to the
exterior parts the bagent vagina is just
the canal the internal portion the stuff
on the outside that's the vulva - stop
saying that word
I was like no bulb evolve evolve evolve
listen I'm doing you a favor okay you
can't just go around the rest of your
life
using vaginas an all-encompassing term
for everything between your legs that's
that's like calling your face your
throat okay like I've always dreamed of
being on Conan like this is huge for me
but might like mom secretly my biggest
dream is it get to perform at an OBGYN
convention like loudest applause but you
just standing screaming so I'm pap smear
kits and numerous and thank you guys
very much
you